ich fühle mich wie ich mich im kreis zu
gestalten hallo ich meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren kontakt hier passend am sonntag
ich habe gerade irgendwie schon das
zweite mal gespuckt oder sich das nur
weil ich diesmal direkt in die kamera
guckt ich habe gar keine ahnung bzw
diese blöde softbox darum ich habe
jedenfalls heute einfach mal bei twitter
gepostet dass ich gar keine idee habe
was ich heute im konter quatschen soll
bzw was ich machen soll keine ahnung ich
sitze vor bc seit einer stunde überlegt
und soll ich das machen
das habe ich schon gemacht über die
dinge die saarbahn die ich irgendwie
nicht mag über dietmar blabla nur habe
ich schon gemacht dann habe ich einfach
mal gefragt dann hab ich mir dachte okay
da kann man so viele sachen an ich bin
einfach mal zehn sachen raus die e mail
geschrieben habt und versucht das
umzusetzen sind fragen und sind ein bild
nahezu nur fragen aber trotzdem viel
schmalz erste frage von jacqueline
becker sagt doch deine meinung zur
legalisierung von cannabis falls du das
noch nicht gemacht haben solltest habe
ich glaub ich noch nicht gemacht und
zwar ist cannabis ja nun in einigen
us-staaten glaube ich und ich weiß nicht
ob schon in deutschland der fall ist in
einigen bundesländern
ich bin mir nicht sicher aber ich glaube
ist nicht in zwei bundesländern schon
erlaubt oder gibt es nicht schon sogar
die ersten copy shops in berlin oder
irgendwie sowas ich habe keine ahnung
jedenfalls kann ich nur zu cannabis
sagen oder allgemein zu gras dass ich
das eigentlich ich sag mal ich nehme es
nicht ich hab sonne gemacht aber was ich
dazu sagen kann ist dass es angeblich es
ist nachgewiesen dass es nicht so
schlimm ist wie alkohol weiber wenn man
alkohol trinkt damit man aggressiv man
es kann
auseinandersetzungen zu stande kommen
man muss davon kotzen wenn man zu viel
davon trinkt aber bei cannabis ist es
halt so man man wird halt einfach nur
ruhig und gechillt und deswegen weiß
nicht also ich finde es eigentlich gar
nicht mal schlecht und die ganze
statistiken belegen eigentlich auch das
cannabis eigentlich sogar weniger
gefährlich ist als alkohol deswegen
finde ich lieber dass man alkohol
kompletter wasser machen sollte und
cannabis tritt nicht am 16 aber auf
jeden fall legalisieren also ich hab nix
gegen eigentlich zweite sache ich soll
einfach nur mies wie ohne emotionen
essen
warum soll ich etwas machen
also ich sehe ich keinen grund darin
warum ich das überhaupt machen sollte
das ist einfach nur weiß ich so eine
frage ist will ich nie umsetzen
schmeckt aber echt lecker irgendwie habe
schon neue ecoflex diesen echt lecker
lecker blue card kellogg's aufgegessen
areal machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
sache und zwar gesagt ich soll einen
einhorn verloren also ich weiß nicht wie
ich ein einhorn irgendwie wie ich das
beschaffen soll oder so aber ich könnte
ja mal eins einfach auch mal
also ohne wird jetzt mal das ist das
aller allerbeste einhorn was ich je
irgendwie gemalt gesehen haben da schaut
euch das mal an das ist einfach nur
total immer das ist megageil
also wenn ihr denn die ohne scheiß wenn
ihr wenn ihr das haben wohl wenn ich
euch dass wenn ihr wenn ich das jetzt
soll es ja verlosen schreibt man einfach
einen orden in die kommentare wenn ich
wenn ihr das haben wollt also ohne
wirklich zeit nochmal es etwa nur
erektion pur ich habe letztens schon mal
gesagt bekommen so dura warte mal viel
zu viel um heißen brei herum kommt man
schnell auf den punkt deswegen will ich
sagen machen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen
schneller und zwar mein maxi king 9 000
bzw
meine nummer 6 ich soll meine wohnung
zeigen die sache ist allerdings die dass
ich zurzeit nur weil meine eltern wohnen
das heißt ich habe nur ein zimmer und
das möchte ich nicht so gern zeigen euch
das ein bisschen zu privat finde was
sich da alles halt rumstehen habe den
ich jetzt nichts falsches oder irgendwie
sowas aber ich werde meine wohnung
zeigen sobald ich umgezogen bin das wird
oktober 2014 sein und dann werdet ihr
halt meine wohnung sehen und
dementsprechend eine room to rupprecht
auch mal die biere nominierung auf
facebook an
interessiert bestimmt einige also an
sich finde ich die sache auch relativ
witzig dass jetzt ein halb rum geht dass
man halt also an alle die die es nicht
kennen die eventuell kein facebook haben
da geht zurzeit so ein trend darum dass
einer wird nominiert der muss dann ein
halber liter bier echsen und der darf
dann drei neue leute nominieren die
müssen das dann innerhalb von 24 stunden
auch machen wenn es nicht machen
schuldet man halt dem typen kasten bier
und ja das will halt irgendwie keiner
dem anderen dann aus tun deswegen
ex-mann auch die leute die man markiert
dann halt ein halber liter bier und dann
geht das halt immer so weiter und das
wird irgendwie silvester 2013 also circa
vor anderthalb monaten ist der trend in
england entstanden und der ist jetzt
rüber bis nach deutschland denn gibt es
auch schon in amerika und überall gibt
es leute die das ganze machen und ich
selber wurde auch schon nominiert aber
ich habe das bisher noch nicht gemacht
also ich habe den leuten immer gesagt
die sollen das wegnehmen weil ich da
noch nicht so weiß nicht ob ich das
machen soll
weil ich das ganze in die relativ
sinnlos finde es ist natürlich witzig
dass man
bier trinkt und dann einfach neue leute
nominiert das ist halt einfach witzig
wenn man von jedem freund irgendwie so
ein video sieht so wurde einfach um gilt
ex das ist halt einfach mega witzig vor
allem die leute die orte an denen das
gemacht wird
aber an sich ist das eigentlich weiß ich
ich find's ganz witzig also keine ahnung
addiert wieder mal so erstatten wir halt
mitte wechseln könnt ihr lieber machen
dass die anderen bei spenden sollen und
so blabla ja aber das ist doch einfach
nur eine witzige aktion und ich meine
man soll nicht mehr nur schlechte sehen
nicole will dass ich meine
lieblingsfilme vorstelle
was habe ich denn eigentlich die
lieblingsfilme ich finde das immer total
schwer so meine lieblingsfilme
rauszusuchen so oft moment genau weil
keine ahnung das ist halt immer so ich
geh ich gucken film und dann fähig den
cool und dann habe ich den aber ein paar
tage später habe ich wieder vergessen
dass ich den cool fand und kann wieder
nicht sagen so ja dass mein
lieblingsfilm oder so also filme die mir
immer noch so im kopf geblieben sind
sind auf jeden fall inception finde ich
mega geil weil einfach so wird der film
ist er so richtig wo du so denkst oh wow
jetzt in dem träume wieder an dem
blablabla dann finde ich das social
network ist richtig geil auf film weil
einfach die entstehung von facebook
zeigt dann finde ich war frustriert
finde ich auch mega gut und sonst
komplett alle batman filme durch sind
auch mega geil und stromberg der film
der ist zwar noch nicht draußen aber mit
mega geil und da werde ich eingehen und
ich werde euch nachts um zwölf uhr keine
ahnung wenn ich eine rezension auf
meinem zweiten analog film dazu machen
weil der film einfach mega geil sein
wird weil stromberg öls halt einfach
kino-besuch mich okay rede brauchen die
kinder also sich ist das natürlich wenn
man sich das meist man überlegt ist es
natürlich mega scheiße weil kinder schon
rauchen weil das ist halt so wenn kinder
rauchen vor allem bei kindern ist es
halt oder denkt man sich jetzt natürlich
der höchster ob kinder oder eltern alles
doch gleich schädlich nein erstmal
grundsätzlich ist das glaube ich nicht
weil bei den kindern ist es halt so dass
alles noch ein wachstum ist das heißt
die organe wachsen noch der körper
wächst die knochen wachsen wenn man dann
raucht oder wenn man irgendwie auch
bodybuilding macht als kind ist sehr
sehr schlecht für den körper weil man
dadurch seine komplette sein komplettes
wachstums zerstört und da alle organe
und der ganze körper einfach noch wächst
quasi im wachstum in der pubertät etc es
ist sehr schlecht wenn man mit solchen
man kann es ja schon quasi giften nennen
den ganzen körper zerstört deswegen
kinder lasst die finger davon wenn jetzt
irgendwie 13 14 seit oder so und
irgendwie ein größerer bruder sagt 18
höhe probieren aber zu hause bist cool
oder so hört auch dass der scheiße das
ist einfach nur kacke deswegen ich
verstehe nicht die ganzen 14 15 jährigen
die dann
irgendwie okay 15 jetzt weiß nicht aber
13 14 jährigen die ja irgendwie schon am
schießstand sind jedes wochenende das
ich versteh's nicht ich meine das ist
einfach damit immer gesagt ja das ist ja
nur hier ein bisschen blubbernde dies
dass eine shisha ist so viel wie mehrere
zigaretten aber neumann schalter nicht
so auf wie man raucht oder man steht ja
auch eigentlich nie alleine aus man ist
eben wie kann er hat keine freunde oder
irgendwie hast aber ich weiß nicht ich
halte davon eigentlich sehr sehr wenig
vor allem allgemein wo dieser
entwicklung mittlerweile hingeht dass
der 14 jährige kinder irgendwelche
videos für die nacht tanzen ins internet
hochladen und wie die sich auch anziehen
und alles ist keine ahnung ich finde die
ich bin so froh dass ich in dieser
jugend ich bin der dame die da
heutzutage ist dies das anders also
brauchen die kinder macht doch mal eine
rundtour oder einen watson myphone #bpw
#bv10 beste alle in die kommentare
schreiben beste partei war room tour wie
gesagt wenn ich erstmal nicht machen
weil es halt zu privat ist aber dieses
potsdamer vor
das habe ich schon mal gemacht aber es
hat sich wieder viel verändert und das
ist auch glaube ich schon ein halbes
jahr mittlerweile zirka her
deswegen schreibt man alle in die
kommentare irgendwie iphone apps zeigen
nur zum opfer und irgendwie sowas mit
frau und mobile blabla wenn ich das
machen soll wenn ihr sehen welche apps
ich auf war auf meinem handy haare weil
dann werde ich das film und wenn ich
male meine apps vorstellen weil da hat
sich einiges angesammelt was auch sehr
hilfreich ist also wenn ihr das wollt
schreibt kommentare worries wir wissen
was ich dazu finde was ich dazu sage was
ich davon halte dass flat vom markt geht
und zwar jetzt gerade ist es 18 16 wenn
ich das geld aufnehmen und zwar seit 16
minuten ist flirt nicht mehr im app
store erhält nicht und auch nicht im
android store da kann man jetzt ruhig
mal nachgucken ich guck mal eben ganz
kurz nach ok das natürlich sehr
interessant bei mir ich werde immer noch
auf der 1 okay ist vielleicht schlecht
gerade zu sehen weil ich aber jetzt auch
keinen bock das irgendwie umzustellen
bei mir ist fertig wird immer noch auf
der 1
angeblich soll seit 18 uhr komplett aus
laptops seien wahrscheinlich wird man
einfach noch nicht aktualisiert nicht
weil irgendwie das ganze juristisch
scheiße geworden ist von wegen hier dass
wir die rechte da gar nichts dran hat
der entwickler nur eine duldung oder
irgendwie so hieß daher verdient
übrigens 50.000 dollar mit dieser
scheiße am tag durch ganz normale
werbeeinnahmen und der ist der einzige
der diese app gemacht hat das ist mega
kraftwerk an der das ist heftig wie wir
damit verdient er sagt aber nur dass
ihnen das ganze halt zum kopf wächst
dass er das dass ihnen das alles viel zu
viel wird was über diese app berichtet
wird die ganzen videos die ganzen leute
die dahin dies durch die luft schmeißen
weil sie da verlieren hier
ich weiß gar nicht mehr so etwas machen
würde eduardo ba sonst finde ich
eigentlich ist es total doof so einer
etwa markt unter zu nehmen weil sie
gerade noch in der entwicklung ist in
der step kann man noch so viel rausholen
sage ich mal durch irgendwelche
challenges und minigames immer noch
machen könnte alles mögliche kann man
mit dieser app machen oder könnt direkt
weiterverkaufen beim alter dass die app
einfach nur raus nimmt und deshalb auch
nicht weiter verkaufen wäre dass er wird
einfach aufhören mit happy bird wird
zwar noch neue spieler entwickeln dabei
wird einfach aufhören und das verstehe
ich einfach nicht weil diese app ist
eine goldgrube und ich bin auch so viele
leute so ein simples spiel deswegen ich
verstehe es nicht warum man so etwas
macht aber gut meine lieben freunde das
ist was worüber ich nicht urteilen
sollte dass es seine persönliche
entscheidung deswegen möchte ich da gar
nicht zwischen funken aber ich würde
sagen es euch gefallen hat lasst einfach
eine positive bewertung da wenn euch so
ein kontakt auch mal gefällt dass ich
einfach auf eure kommentare bei twitter
eingibt twitter könnt ihr auch folgen
da heißt es konkreter und bei instagram
herzlich laser luca und bei facebook
kann kräfte tv bleibt wenn die alten in
der beschreibung und natürlich sagen
schreiben sie kommentare besonders mal
vor nächste woche haben wollte und sonst
für die sache informiert bei anderen
macht's gut und schau
ich fühle mich wie ich mich im kreis
drehen die kugel